[Music]
we are here in Atlanta Susan left go and
some Simza left o faithful we appreciate
you guys what
how you feeling since this is the real
faithful right here Wednesday a Super
Bowl akuze down holy crap dude and Suzy
in the back holding it down Aaron Rogers
faithful the ceremonial podcast to get
it going for the week yeah
I've already started sweating yes which
is kind of a staple yeah right he just
had some wings backstage and it was
pouring off of him and I was like maybe
he's gonna be the sweaty one no yeah I'm
still the same that's right that doesn't
happen he's a drink in - look at him
over there yeah we get some more 1942 on
the rocks with two limes please I'd like
to do that I always wanted to do that
with a mic in my hand all right I do
want to do something really quick just
for the constitution if you can raise
your right hand
Aaron Rogers is the greatest quarterback
we have ever seen Brady is like no one
is our favorite coach in the NFL and
beans not beef I want to give up this
meat okay we'll get you there I want to
give a shout out also to all the people
Sims enough go show all the people care
and Todd Nicole Sean everybody that
helped put this place together it looks
awesome thank you so much we have a huge
week when I say that I've seen the guest
list and some of the names are like oh
crap
yeah including tonight I am very very
excited here's how this is gonna work
for everyone that's not here we're
publishing these podcasts as soon as we
get done it's gonna go on you too then
you guys can listen to it for you here
please order a drink let's enjoy this
Tuesday Wednesday we're here at 5
o'clock Thursday 5 o'clock and that's
gonna be the show and when I say it's
gonna be special if we're competing with
I don't know tio and Chad Johnson and
then maybe the best quarterback in the
NFL is here to Thursday's gonna be
really awesome yeah we got some studs
coming and then Friday and excited yeah
like I am and then Friday 4:30 that's
gonna be our last podcast before the
Super Bowl that's when we're going to
do like our game pics in our bedding
segment and that's also I mean there are
some names there that I can't believe
they agreed yes right so this report
must have paid a lot of money to get
these guys here because I mean they
couldn't have really wanted to come to
see you but I could me me me me you I
don't know I don't know I don't know
there were some people yelling for me at
media and I know they were what did you
think of media night that's the first
time I've ever gone first time ever been
to media night it is crazy just the
spectacle that the NFL and the Superbowl
has grown into I still like it the old
way the old way the old way they used to
just have it on the stadium right do you
guys remember that like back in the day
I know this it's it's like maybe a night
no it wasn't a night but they would have
it on the day on the actual stadium to
where you could get a peek of like how
this I'm into like I can't wait to see
the Superbowl field ok I'm a nerd like
how its painted and one of the cool end
zones gonna look like is it gonna be a
silver New England or a blue New England
you know what I mean I just I was that
crap I know I'm I'm kind of a football I
was surprised that the Patriots like
everybody was wearing great gray hoodies
yeah
and Belichick decided to wear a suit
yeah like the one time it was socially
acceptable for him to wear a hoodie
right I got the sleeves on your right to
it that was kind of kind of weird you're
right Sean McVeigh so he knew my name he
did know you kind of got me a little
excited so we're doing this thing this
week and it's gonna be for the show on
Thursday where if you remember Sims
thinks that I can actually throw the
ball 50 yards and we went and asked that
to all the players so that'll be on the
show on Thursday
I'll wait do you see it but it's alright
they looked at me and he was like left
oh man and it kind of hurt my i love
Cole like we'd always I'd we'd always
get a keep to leave somebody to like
size them up right and let's go and like
pose and be like what do you think can I
throw there look at my legs and it's not
any wanted to touch my thighs no now
where the power comes from thought
they'd like some insight for
Oh much hello thank you so much oh very
nice of you all right yeah if you have a
drink raise it to the sky to a great
Super Bowl may it be fantastic and may
the team that you're rooting for are
betting for win and to you guys yeah
sure soil listeners and initiate that ed
to you - humming 1940 to 1942 you make
me feel so good all right so we're gonna
go one more thing about last night one
more thing I'm really afraid we're gonna
I'm not gonna go crazy about anything
last night I just want to say I thought
it was really cool if you guys saw a
meteor night last night you pointed it
out to me but then I went back and
watched the clothes a golf comment the
golf and Brady like so Chris Rose tried
to echo golf into going
did you watch Tom Brady's Super Bowls
growing up because if you notice on
social media right now it's how old was
Gronk when Tom Brady won it's like this
storyline that everyone's obsessed with
and I thought goth actually handled it
really well I did you got basically was
like one of them the Panthers one like
which we know is not true and then they
asked Brady to give golf advice and he's
like I'm not doing that so to me that
means like game is on like we're done
with like oh this is we're so proud to
be here and I appreciate both
quarterbacks doing that because I hate
that crap like I don't want you to like
each other the week of the game right
and nor should Tom Brady be going like
you know giving to Jared Goff like
tricks of the trade
well usually on Monday nights I do this
Jared yeah that's not part of the sport
you know there's got to keep the little
I robberies I'm nervous for Jared
because I think it's a big stage and
we've had doubts for him for a long time
well you had doubts from the NFC
Championship game I had doubts when we
met him before he got drafted I don't
think any of us are eg no well no I
think he shook our hands and he didn't
make eye contact and it kind of mate it
which is such a dumb thing to care about
yeah like it makes me think of all
remember like the Jim Haslam article
sure he didn't want Teddy Bridgewater
because it wasn't a good hand yet I'm
Jimmy Haslam right now well and I just
ah you're not Jimmy Azzam not that crazy
you're crazy but like it is like I think
a lot of people had those same concerns
coming out in the draft he is not like
golf is not a guy like a Tom Brady or an
Aaron Rodgers or Cam knew
whoever it may be who just comes into
the room and is like this is my room I
got embarrassed out here I'm gonna
embarrass job yeah
when Tom Brady walked out right and they
were like Tom Brady and the place
exploded Josh goes to me goes I can't
believe I'm in the same room as Tom Bree
well he was he was like that and they
got the elevator with Peyton Manning
remember in Knoxville Tennessee he told
that story you ever tell you that's
their home he got in the elevator and
hate Manning got in and Josh's like
mother hen you know you know you know
Josh yes I know they know Josh I don't
know if he does so I'm just trying to
explain to him right there but but my
buddy he he gets in and Peyton Manning
comes in the elevator right after him
and like josh is usually mr. proper like
oh I'm gonna respect his privacy and but
he had a shake a man's hand and just
like how mr. Manning Oh big friend of
yours that in that voice I put your
stats in an Excel spreadsheet amazing
now you are amazing all right so we're
gonna do our Super Bowl preview we're
gonna do a complete deep dive and I want
to start off with the coaches Jim Nantz
is gonna wax poetic about how it's a 66
year old Bill Belichick / - 33 year old
Shawn McVeigh he's gonna talk about the
romance of it all we know that Belichick
in every game goes what are they best at
and I'm taking it away yeah so now that
you've had time to think about it right
not rushing right what is Bill Belichick
gonna take away from the RAM there is no
glaring thing like this is not tyree
kill right of the Chiefs or this is not
like Oh Keenan Allen for the Chargers on
third down we know he's Philip Rivers
go-to guy right I think when when you
break down the Rams offense some of the
beauty of their offense is that the two
receivers really all three even 83
Reynolds they're they're interchangeable
there's no weakness or great strength to
any of them right so like you know we
know Tyree kills the deep guy for the
Kansas City Chiefs and he's the guy
that's explosive and they're gonna scare
scared the defense and everything with
it Robert Woods Brandon cooks we've
talked about it a lot they're very
similar and they can do the same thing
so they don't have to be ones the speed
guy once a deep guy both can beat you
deep both can run great underneath
routes the option routes
are so important yeah so I don't think
that's going to be it I don't think it's
really gonna be tight end play I think
it's really going to start with stopping
the inside zone run game I think that's
where the Rams offer them
one-dimensional takeaway the play action
layer number one play action team in
football this season so how do you think
Belichick is going to go about stopping
right I don't think it's gonna be
anything that's gonna make them have to
leave their you know realm of comfort
right where if you watch the Patriots
play they love to play the bear front
anyways and you guys know what the bear
front is if we taught you enough about
that like the bear front where you're
gonna put three big defensive lineman
right over the center in the center
guard to basically go okay you want to
up the middle you know go ahead but we
got like 950 pounds there to make things
hard and you did you roll the dice on
that so I do think you're gonna see that
right off the bat to disrupt the inside
zone and then they're gonna play the
backers I would believe unlike the
outside shade to contain to contain not
only for the zone but when they see the
speed sweep coming just in case be oh I
gotta get upfield and stop a Brandon
cooks who's trying to go around the edge
I think that is the first thing you have
to start with the stop the ramp I have
advice for Bill Belichick yes
one-for-one definitely makes sense huh
you have what bill listen to me here's
the game plan if I'm Bill Belichick
everyone's standing everyone's damn sure
let Sean McVeigh look out and he's in
there going Jared I'm gonna tell you
what to do oh no my microphones gonna
cut off they're all standing and then at
15 yeah completely switch your defense
sure because you're gonna see some of
that I just think they've relied on this
so long of Sean McVeigh looking out and
then making a decision just confuse them
until 15 it's a valid point left go and
I wouldn't be shocked if you saw them do
it especially on third downs but I would
say this this is one thing I would say
Rams go tempo I would think the Rams
learn from the Saints game like it's
still the Superbowl it's not gonna be as
latter-day Super Dome but it's still
gonna be loud you can't always be at the
line of scrimmage trying to direct
traffic right it's just too hard you're
right guard mine duck get the right call
the left tackle might not get the right
call so and you have to imagine this
could be a very Pro Patriots crowd I
I don't know I don't even know the Super
Bowl I don't you think I don't think
Rams fans are gonna travel I mean we
can't talk about how the Rams don't have
fans all year and then all of a sudden
be like nah but they're gonna match the
Patriots fans well no I'm just I'm
thinking that all the innocent
bystanders that are at the game they're
all gonna go for the RAM I guess
everyone's mad at the Patriots so you're
gonna have your Boston true New England
guys right yeah but I think like any
like Johnny corporation guys gonna go
I've seen the New England Patriots
enough it's gonna be going right now I
mean the sweet Peter King article where
he's talking he's interviewing Sean
McVeigh and he mentioned that the Eagles
on that Zach Ertz touchdown
went four by one and it was a formation
that Belichick has never seen yeah and
that and he brought it up making me
think that maybe McVeigh said something
like that what kind of wrinkles do you
think McVeigh could at like could we see
an entirely new scheme from him I don't
think so I don't think he will do that
but to your point which i think is very
real like we've talked about it a
million times and you play the Patriots
right they're gonna know every play
you've ever run self scout thyself you
have to self scout when you play the
Patriots put that on a pillow scout
thyself yeah I can't I like the thigh
part it just makes it sound more
intelligent doesn't it thigh I sound
like I'm an intelligent guy but that's
where I truly do think it starts if bill
and you get in certain formations he's
gonna have he truly is like Johnny
Google spreadsheet that's what I did for
him like there was I broke down plays
and there was 32 played 32 columns per
play and at the start of their base
preparation they're gonna start to
filter columns and see if they can find
trends right and start to go like oh
okay they're in this formation they'd
like to run these routes or they're in
this down a distance and it always seems
like they throw the ball here on this
down a distance just does Bill have a
photographic memory
yes so you put that all into a
spreadsheet he looks at it and it's
there forever yes like the the first you
know America's game Belichick wasting
this incredible brain on football
probably I mean I probably could do a
lot of things worldwide but I mean I
don't know if it's a waste when you're
but yes would you like
check his president I would yes I know
I'd like building anything like I always
say it bill worked on Wall Street he'd
be leaned on he'd be the wolf he'd be
running Wall Street it doesn't matter
where he is he'd be running the show cuz
he's that brilliant of a guy yes I mean
he is like I mean Sean my face not that
far behind but if you ever watch
America's game the original one with
Belichick he's literally like the games
going on I believe they're playing the
Ravens in the playoffs the year they
lose like Ray Rice breaks the long run
the middle he's sort of like that's
place 64 from week 15
that's play 61 from week four like he
and he's on the sideline he's not even
looking over like reading information he
knows he's just that kind of brilliant
man all right let's go do you want to
talk Patriots offense or Rams like one
more thing just from that already wanna
Graham's offense just I do think it's
going to be cool to see let's start
there yeah just the the Rams offense you
talked about what we talked about Bella
cheque might take away the coverage
aspect is gonna be interesting too I
mean I don't think there's anybody in
football plays more man-to-man than the
Patriots the Rams are not the type of
team that has a lot of necessarily pick
plays and things like that I would think
that would be something they maybe break
out you want to talk about new wrinkles
yes because the two corners for New
England and Stephon Gilmore the fact
that he got to practice against a
Brandon cooks last year all year long
that favors in my opinion the db2 that
yes I hosted that show with Lombardi
last week so Michael Lombardo the guy
that worked with Belichick and all that
stuff and he said that he knows that
their plan for Brandon cooks is to beat
the hell out of them yeah that whoever
is over him at the line right jamón push
them slam them and whoever they think
can do that the best yeah that's what
they're put in there I I think that's a
when you're watching the game he's gonna
be a rag doll Turley Gilmore and JC
Jackson are big corners they're really
awesome and they can play man-to-man and
Bill is not afraid to put them in some
uncomfortable spots and the other thing
too that New England will do I think
when they get in these tight splits New
England will use their defensive ends to
just go and you want to be close we're
gonna hit you and then rush and stop the
what happens as a quarterback is if
Brandon cooks is your first option and
all sudden the DN hits him golf drops
back and he
hits his fifth step and he's like wait
wait Brandon cooks isn't there at the
top of his route yet right now he gets
to the second read and all of a sudden
the second reads not there yet cuz he's
gotten to it too quickly and it really
messes up your whole play and then
that's when Jared golf's going you've
seen it do you guys he looks like Jared
Goff you do right a little bit right
they've the helmet on yeah yeah the
helmet on this section of my face is
Jared Goff this section is Jared Goff
Steen we know where we're going right
yeah
stay with Rams offense Patriots defense
Rams offensive line right Patriots D
line right who has the edge that's a
close one uh III guess if you gave me
the edge I'm going to go with the
Patriots there but it's close
so the weakness is Austin Blythe yes and
then it's all of a center right so who
do the Patriots put there to take
advantage yeah there's that Trey flowers
yeah it could be on certain situations I
mean they will move Trey flowers down
there but you're gonna see Malcolm Brown
Lawrence guy Danny shelves all gonna
take their turns and New England's not
like the Eagles or even necessarily the
bears all the way like New England
doesn't give their defense alignment
like the green light to go get upfield
if you guys have ever heard us talk
about New England like even when they
play that bear front they are going to
like they want to just hold their ground
bill doesn't want anybody to go flying
after any you know fire trucks or
anything stay in your spot hold the guy
up and read the play and basically just
clog the middle and then as the runner
gets close this is what - gapping is try
to disengage and then make the tackle
and New England can do that New England
is a really big football team like
they're big a lot bigger than you
realize on TV TV does not do them
justice this is the ultimate speed verse
size team and New England with brown
Shelton Lawrence guy yes Dante Hightower
who's 270 pounds at linebacker there
they're going to be a different force
than what what the ran development
called Shawn mcvane he picked up yeah
and he said Sims what's your advice yeah
offensively what would be your big
advice I think I already said it with
the self scowl
thy self yeah I think that's the biggest
thing if you think you're gonna go into
the game ago we're just gonna run what
we've been running all year long
and it'll work you're gonna be in for a
rude awakening Warren sharp had a lot of
statistics today that came out that the
formation the Rams use the most is
actually the formation that the Patriots
have been weakest against which is the
11 percent personnel and that when the
Rams 2 11 and 11 means one running back
one tight end three wide receivers
if the Rams do that yeah and the running
game is successful right this game is
going to be incredible if the Rams if
you see CJ Anderson and Todd Gurley
having success early which means Jared
Goff can do the play-action the third
and fourth quarter
we might get a 34 31 we could but if you
see CJ Anderson and Todd Gurley not
getting the ball off early none of that
stuff's gonna work late no so really I'm
I'm kind of rooting I want it to be a
shootout yeah I mean I hear you it's
it's a fun game to watch
I actually if you actually like what
another curveball the Rams offense could
do yeah
as I do think just maybe stay in the
shotgun spread the field don't worry
about always bringing the receivers in
the Titans the Patriots are big they're
big and you're fast exactly you play to
their strike that ray right you're not
gonna beat them in a phone booth but you
get them out there in space that's more
of the Rams game and I wouldn't be
shocked if they got away from you know
golf under the center running the inside
zone so much maybe just gotten shotgun
and said okay you want to load the ba
box you want to play the bear front and
try to stop the run well we got some
matchups on the outside where are we
thinking we have the advantage Patriots
offense Rams defense yeah I mean how
transcendent does Aaron Donald have to
be for them to win this game I I mean I
think he's going to have to have one of
the best games of his life and like you
were the Rams and you could put him on
any of those offensive linemen ya know
we're just gonna focus on this the whole
time right who would it be I think the
one guy if there's any weakness there
with the the Patriots Donald
Anthony our tuna tuna tuna okay I was
yes that was like that would be
especially in passing situations run
game hey that interior oh line of the
Patriots is the real deal Holyfield Shaq
Mason and
but Tunis is not great in past fro he's
been better this year than other years
but that would be the one I would say oh
they're gonna try to get Donald matched
up on him and make sure that the center
can't slide and help out you know put
three other linemen on this side to
where they have to stay over there so
another thing that I saw today
statistically is that the Patriots have
been great lately at the big shots right
and if the Rams it's one of their big
issues with the defense's they allow big
shot yeah I would assume the big shots
go on Peters because he's willing to
take so many more rescue is it
definitely going to Edelman like do you
like is he gonna be a part of the big
plays in this game or do you see other
people like a Dorsett coming out of
nowhere I haven't seen cordarrelle
Patterson go out for like a pass inferno
you're right it's been a while I mean
Edelman will be the main focus I don't
think he'll be the guy they're gonna
look to throw like the 50-yard bomb too
but all the 15 to 25 yard plays like
it's going to be out and why is New
England got better at the shot place I
mean you guys have been watching them
right
I mean it's Smash Mouth football run it
run it and then all of a sudden
Brady keeps it on play action and the
linebackers haven't stopped it right and
they're up in the line of scrimmage and
all of a sudden they turn around and
they go oh damn Edelman is behind us for
another 20 yard gain that's where
they've really upped their game in
general and when you talk about the
Patriots Rams matchup my biggest concern
and I think I send a little last week if
you guys listened is goes back to the
size thing once again have you guys ever
seen Rob Gronkowski in person it's like
seeing I have a transformer in him Trent
Brown Marcus Cannon like again there's
something about the New England uniform
that doesn't make them look big in
person almost like Georgia
I mean Georgia if you go on the field
you go there's something maybe with the
silver pants there's no doubt about it
but no way that seems that was
completely made-up that's true I think
sometimes it is because like the Cowboys
could be the same way like you were
shocked when you saw Tyrone Smith the
first time in person - I wish I could
like go on Tyron stmas back and be like
let's run that way I was like riding a
tiger but I do think that's where I
worry for the Rams the size factor okay
but the biggest thing is they don't play
a lot of people on defense and that
always scares me against New England
because New England is
well oiled machine and I would the game
always starts with all right no England
balichek Medina's ago who can ruin the
game and they're gonna go okay ninety
nine and ninety three can ruin the game
how do we stop them and then they
literally grow the playbook from there
which is genius what they do because
they're not gonna let the most obvious
people that we all expect their people
in the game
they go we're not gonna let that happen
is that more incredible then to go to my
Eagles fandom that t/o had seven catches
for like 131 in that game I I think it's
amazing and I think it's like I think
like Belichick probably didn't believe
it he's I called their bluff because I
can't can't be that hell yeah there's no
way all right you want some left cone
nugget yeah I do I love them alright
first off McVeigh in his entire career
yeah has 26 wins right Belichick has 30
wins in just the playoffs a Wade
Phillips vs. McDaniels this is actually
the tenth time that they faced off this
is actually the worst defense perdy VOA
which is Football Outsiders that he's
ever had to face McDaniel right not a
good sign for the Rams I added it up
yeah in the last nine games the Patriots
have averaged just over 29 points per
game right against Wade Phillips so I
know everyone loves Wade but the problem
is is when Belichick says last week
Wade's been able to play the same
defense for this entire career right
it's also a bad thing because that means
Belichick is going to know what it is
and realize that number would be so much
higher but Wade had those Denver team us
that were the number one defense in the
league for three what he was in Houston
they got shredded apart yes there's the
Houston D coordinator and they charge
these Chargers had some success one time
what the Chargers had the very first
time and any listen I'll say this to
forget the stats of the Rams defense all
year it doesn't matter right you know
just like we've seen the Patriots in
years past with like some bad defense
but the Rams especially because it
there's no like X's and O's explanation
I could give your is this really it all
comes down to this like the Rams got a
lot of badass [ __ ] on their
defense okay that's where the first
curse hey when you
two weeks to prepare and everybody's
telling you Brady's this and that you've
got to perform and play the game of your
life like though these guys are going to
rise to the occasion just like we've
seen the RAM Steve must do the last two
weeks right there was question marks oh
damn they stonewalled by the Cowboys Oh
drew reason company rather sue takes it
to another level yes it's big players
they can turn it up a notch when they
need to all right another left cone
nugget for you left go sprinkle
Belichick versus quarterbacks with three
years experience or less in the playoffs
it's happened 12 times
what's balichek's record 12 all right so
three years of experience or less in the
playoffs 12 times I wouldn't say he's
tenant - that's you're crazy I'm crazy -
Joe or that go he lost - yep okay and
Mark Sanchez damn I'm good you're
annoying all right here's what's
incredible about Joe Flacco Joe Flacco
in that game past four times and the
Ravens ran at 52 so it wasn't even like
Joe Flacco did it it was just an
incredible great writer and the art
Sanchez and Mark Sanchez was the only
one to even top 60% passing
yeah there were similar teams great
defense run the football and these
aren't scrum now Big Ben Phillip Rivers
Flacco Andrew Luck Andrew Luck Russell
Wilson mahomes man and dirt ten and two
against those guys right and this is
Jared so it shows you that Jared Goff
eat them no charlie players Tom Brady in
a dome 11 and three his quarterback
rating is thirteen points better in a
dome Jared Goff one in three in a dome
his one win was last week similar but
his quarterback rating was down so those
are just a few left go spring yeah and
I'm gonna give you my left go betting
well do you what do you want to sum up
is there anything else about the game
that you want to kind of know I think
the biggest thing about the game that
kind of started on it was just I worried
about the Rams defense and their depth
right just like you saw last week I
don't know if you guys heard me say it
when we did them deep dive podcast but
damn I mean the Patriots have already
played like five of the best pass
rushers in football now not on the top
by but right Houston D Ford Chris Jones
Ingram BOCES and nobody's even got to
smell Tommy's breath you
I mean nobody's even gotten close what
does Tom Brady's breath smell like I
would think avocado thank you something
along those lines do you think anyone
would have the confidence to go Tom need
a brother like or do you think they'd be
like oh like he liked it ray Louis no
I'm like a teammate's oh no no I could
see Edelman have at it right he'd be the
one guy but I got see chronic you had
bacon but I do worry about the depth
issue just because of the amount of
place like we've seen nobody's got close
to Brady because they wear you out
mentally and physically they really do
it's just this array of the most complex
run game there is the most complex
play-action pass game then it's some of
the best screens in football and as a
deal I'm and where you're going all year
get the quarterback get the quarterback
halls and you're like oh gosh it's soni
Michelle oh gosh it's Tony Michelle
again oh it's sorry oh no it's not Sony
Michelle they're throwing it oh I'm
going to get something Michelle oh no
it's Julian Edelman serene on the edge
and they wear teams out with their pace
as they do it to like New England's
gonna get to appear to the game and
they're gonna go let's just get up to
the line of scrimmage and call place and
Tom's did a look and they're all he's
gonna say a cold word he might just say
refrigerator refrigerator and they know
the play and they're gonna line up
really quick and he's gonna get out of
there and he's gonna go you know oh my
go and he's gonna go and they're gonna
run it and they're gonna keep the pace
up and all of a sudden you're gonna go
man it's the fourth quarter white
where's this pass rush where where are
they and you go well they've it's 78th
play they don't have depth they've been
out there the whole game and that's what
I worry about a lot like the Seahawks in
Super Bowl xlix remember that great
defense right they at the end of the
game she dumped ounce a henna throw the
ball game they just kept on it quick and
they could never get to him and all of a
sudden that great Seattle defense didn't
really get the show it's greatness all
right so these are my gambling sort of
advice looking at all the props and
again everybody knows my gambling streak
so don't take this too serious but I
actually have been more what do you mean
is your streak bad I mean come on Milo
Locke's finished 500 okay which is
incredible the blood a comeback like I
ever
zillions 8 and 2 playoff some eight and
two right oh yeah thank you
I mean damn well though I was gonna
build myself up I gotta be your hype man
yes sure in this corner first thing is
11 of the 12 casino still have it at
Patriots -2 and a half one of them has
it at Patriots -3 but almost all the
bets are going on New England right now
so the Vegas their team right now is the
Rams because you know they take the
other side so I always like to be on the
side of Vegas I think that the only bet
if you're betting this game that makes
sense as a gambler is the Rams money
line the Rams winning outright the weird
thing about gambling is that it's not
about who do you think is gonna win it's
about where's the value so now I know
I'm getting very degenerate on you but
plus I'm enjoying it yeah so plus 120
for the Rams there's a lot of value
there the other thing is I was saying
these to you earlier right now the
public and Super Bowls apparently always
bets the over because there's all the
excitement of the two weeks where
everyone's like oh and he can score in
Gronk and Edelman and Sony Michelle and
it oh it usually hits the under too same
thing happen with the Pro Bowl as a
player I would always think the ender
nerves play a factor in these games to
where the offense in Tom Brady dropped a
pastor I mean yeah this is are nervous
defenses get to go out and play they're
like oh there's ball me go tackle ball
yeah offense is like oh gosh this check
whole-wheat coach told me if Aaron
Donald's over here I got to get to this
and all of a sudden you know you just
start to mess up this so you feel the
pressure in the moment you miss a throw
or a guy fumbles of all whatever and
this is the bets that I'm actually going
to make so I'm sharing this with you
right now
I love prop bets I'm not betting on the
coin flip 89% of people are taking heads
I would fade them in go tails not about
that I'm not gonna bet the national
anthem and how it should be around 136
but I think she's gonna go under oh you
think
no under I think it's over - you think
people ham it up for the Super Bowl
I think she's straight business he wants
to show those vocal cords but the one
that I love is this could be Gronk's
last game in fact you believe it is
grown
/ yes you believe that he's definitely
retiring I really I mean my first thing
would be he looks sad all season well
all offseason I mean New England doesn't
try to get rid of you and trade you
unless they think that either you're
done or it's coming to the very end
remember they were contacting Detroit
trying to push it right so that worries
me we talked about it a million times
during the year we never saw that Gronk
attitude or like beast mode this year
where you know he gets up and he shakes
his head and he looks at the ball and
spike he didn't do that to me that's
like sees some of the emotions out yes
and then last night he got asked
point-blank and anybody who was coming
back to play would just go like Tom
Brady did there's zero chance I'm coming
back right so the fact that he didn't
squash that tells me that it's a very
real possibility of of Grunk when i
factor in the fact that the rams
linebackers are fast but they're under
size smaller when i factor in that
LaMarcus Joyner and John Johnson are at
safety are fast but they're not big and
the one thing Grunk still has a size I'm
going all in on the Gronk bets all of
them Vegas has them at three and a half
catches taken the over they have met 55
and a half receiving yards I'm taking
the over score a touchdown no is the
favorite II I'm going yes plus 170 and
I'm just saying that if you bet on
anyone other than a quarterback it's
kind of stupid it's either gonna be
Brady or golf but I think if you're
gonna take a long bet there's two guys I
would bet on to maybe hit and that would
be Aaron Donald and Gronk yeah because
if the Rams win Aaron Donald has to have
a big game and I like Gronk
and Gronk is 30 to 1 to be the MVP so
I'm just saying I am personally gonna be
making those bets if you lose and you go
with me I apologize but I'll be losing
too so we'll share this misery together
it'll be great I but God your logic is
pretty good though yeah because I think
also when you factor into Leoben Peters
okay let's say that scratch is off
Edelman and another receiver then
they're going
load up because they don't want to get
beat by Sony Michelle right crunk III
and then you'd added in the fact that
you said it's small linebackers yes it's
a smaller defensive front and now ok the
linebackers are worried about the run
game Rams are aggressive anyways guys
like Littleton and Marc Baron or 230 and
225 yes they're gonna try to meet people
in the hole in the running game and that
can lead to play-action Gronk behind ya
so so that's my nugget that's what I'm
feeling onto something that and then
Lombardi told me to bet James White
carries he thinks that the Patriots are
gonna run a lot with James White because
most people see them passing the Jamie
rice icon so that's all my information
alright so in the NFL this year there
were a few rookies that I think burst on
the scene they were phenomenal
Derwin James with the Chargers he here
absolutely unbelievable who Derwin James
no he's not here Nick Chubb I thought
was absolutely fantastic all the
quarterbacks were really good but I
believe that the best rookie on the NFL
was not a running back or a wide
receiver a quarterback or a defensive
end or a safety or a linebacker it was
an offensive lineman who and he got the
call his owner said hey Quinton what's
up man and Quinton is with us right now
[Music]
[Applause]
Quinton oh look at it
look at you understand how you doing
tell you that before
that's why Sims and I looked at the
chairs well I don't know about this
right now
but you want to drink seriously though
you sure all right
how are you q I just want to say to
personally thank you for liking my
pictures on Instagram you're the man I
it like changes his life Quinn he's like
oh oh Quinn Quinton liked my thing shut
up Sammy Quinton I got you a present
let's go here you go you didn't have to
do that you can read the card to the
little attachment we open up right now
let's go down there no this is strictly
for me and for my personal
I got Amazon points for it he doesn't
even buy his girlfriend crap that's not
true yeah what does the note say hey
Quentin what's up man
dude that was amazing when Irsay called
you and said that but I got a little
present because I saw you in the
playoffs and I realized there's a theme
here and while Quinton enjoys pancaking
defenders and smashing people off the
blocks there's one thing he doesn't like
and that is sleeves nice so what I got
for you oh that's a that's a
high-quality shirt right there
it is a Catalina Wine Mixer tank so cute
well I figured you like stepbrothers and
so Catalina Wine Mixer so you can let
the guns out all right so can I get the
monitor up really quick is that possible
because the first thing that we need to
talk about here Quinn wait first of all
did you see me that day one well I'll
wait till it pops I'll show it we met
before it you know that right right
Notre Dame NBC I mean gosh I was the
first guy that told everybody like damn
McGlinchey is good but Nelson's the man
I mean maybe he's the man too he's the
man I know yes don't be me all right I
want I want to talk about this yes this
is the day that you saw Quinton L sight
in Kansas City yes quit did you know
this was gonna blow up at all uh no I
wasn't thinking about it that's how I
always dress when I go out for a pregame
and and honestly wasn't that cold
I got it can be like cold out but as
long as it's not windy like when it gets
really windy I don't know if any of you
guys are from Chicago I went to school
in South Bend Notre Dame and the wind
man like it just goes through everything
and that that's when you get super cold
but since you were wearing like a
bundled up
this is him talking I even told his crap
he could say whatever you was like damn
can we get back inside but you I was
about to do a hit for the game and you
were running out of the locker room you
know right where has that big sign and I
know you didn't see me and he had other
things you were focused on in the world
but I saw you coming out of that little
tunnel to get into the main
Tunnel right right outside of your Lobby
yeah and I was like oh my gosh look at
this guy he is I already knew you were a
gigantic human being but the funniest
thing about it is not watching him in
that outfit
it's watching him walk by the
groundskeepers and all the people taking
care of the stadium and as Quintin walks
by they're all like it's all like it's
like National Geographic they're like
what is this guy I've never seen a human
like this I mean that's that's what they
look here and I'm still looking at you
like that I mean can you this is a guard
this is a really good guard and he could
beat the crap out of all of us at the
same time what is it like for everyone
to call you like the best offensive lime
in the NFL and you just played one year
it's it's a lot of I feel like over hype
really yeah I mean I have bad plays all
the time and I but I'll have some like
highlight plays that'll like go viral at
the same time but uh it's like you can't
go way to meet others I don't know what
you mean but uh yeah I mean there's so
many other offensive linemen that I
watch every week in preparing for other
teams like so many other guards that
like I just appreciate watching and I
think there think the world of them and
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't say I'm the
best I want to be yeah hopefully like
one day who are the other one that you
want like oh wow they should be getting
more respect well I mean a lot of the
ones i watch already get a lot of
respect like sac martin de castro yonder
Buitoni oh all these guys think of Joe
Tunney sure yeah Patriots really good I
like watching him a lot yeah and I mean
there's other ones out there too so this
was one of those viral moments that were
playing behind us right now
where the Colts took a video of you
destroying a linebacker for the
Jacksonville Jaguars and then had you
screaming and it really blew up the
internet that day because everyone
thought you were a lunatic you came
around the end just going on
I'm just curious what that experience is
like for you yeah I got I mean my phone
was blowing up after the game it was
really good we won but uh I had so many
texts and people are like are you okay
what's wrong with you you psycho and I
was like I ended up like stopping I I
didn't respond to everyone because I I
had so many texts I was like I'm not
explaining this but I'll explain it on
the show yes so I there was another play
in the game where we ran fake power
right where I pulled okay
and Andrew faked the ball and kept it
under the boot bootleg it was third of
one right so on that play I yelled while
pulling to try to get the linebackers to
come with me
gotcha thank you did weak to say yell to
draw the attention or you just did
eating your own a veteran on our team s
Lawson had told me that once yeah and I
applied it there so then they took the
audio from that play and put it in on
the play
yeah that went viral and I mean I was
pretty upset because I I didn't want to
get miked up in the first place so I got
not that type of guy too much but uh
yeah I mean it lets you getting fined
like $25,000 yeah did the Colts pick up
the tab on that I got my fine and I went
up into the media room and swam the
paper on the maybe guy's desk he was
just like I'm so sorry man like oh yeah
vamo requested him $26,000 he didn't
accept it but that's amazing I was gonna
say can you imagine like alright what am
I gonna put on Twitter today yeah
quittin walks in right I want to crap my
pants
that's amazing it is unbelievable
alright so like you played the Patriots
earlier this year yeah okay that's where
I'd like to start just like what jumped
out to you about playing them even like
the personnel just blocking some of the
guys Lawrence guy Shelton Brown
I mean Danielle like you have Malcolm
Brown yeah they all use very good
technique there do their D lineman
their linebackers are very solid but I
mean everyone just does their job and
they play very sound football they don't
make a lot of mistakes and I mean yeah
there will be some like big plays here
and there but for the most part like
they're not gonna bring it up moving
yeah and yeah they're an impressive team
for you for you through the year like
you were one of the best guards in
football I'll say that but I just like
what were some of the matchups of the
year where you're like man that was that
was a tough day's work right there that
guy's a freaking nature whoever who like
that might first thought that would be
the first game of the season
yeah against Gino Atkins all right for
the Bengals going into the game as I
guard and I'm just gonna use my
technique and all this stuff and I had
no idea what was coming
he bull rushed me so many times and I
was just like holy cow
I was like welcome to there's a welcome
to that I felt like right game now yeah
not just moment I was like my body was
my back was hurting everything was
hurting I was like 16 weeks of this yeah
come on yes and no but uh he was a beast
worried about his speed so much that you
let gets led to being Bell rushed but
those guys like to where you're so
worried about like you know get my feet
moving I got worried about his speed and
yeah they catch you off-guard you could
definitely get caught off-guard worrying
about their speed right but I mean for
Gino
he's not the tallest but that kind of
helps him because his pad level is so
good and his hands are inside like
there's there was like nothing for me to
punch in that game and I was just like
eating his bulrush like every play and
like straining my back out yeah yeah
he's pretty Jack he's almost like a
errant Donald ish type of guy that's who
Aaron Donald said he modeled his game
after growth yeah that makes sense
ha and he talked about eating so I
looked up and apparently you're like a
chef and it all comes down to sandwiches
apparently you are infamous at Notre
Dame for turning anything into a
sandwich are you a chef's make
sandwiches listen he's a she's a chef
Sam what
Jamaica but apparently your egg
sandwiches are like legendary what is
your secret oh wise one haha
I mean probably an English muffin it
would be on game day especially when we
had a early game and you know just
toasted English muffin butter it then
put some bacon on it and like I think
it's how much time I put into it like
it's not the same it's a masterpiece
I got to make it as perfect as possible
and like my teammates at Notre Dame
would just like enjoy like just watching
me and it made me uncomfortable like
dude stop watching me I'm trying to just
so you'd have like an audience for your
sandwich making are you still making a
lot of sandwiches now yeah yeah for sure
man
why that's the hard-hitting [ __ ] you get
here sandwich maker what are we tipping
the scales at right now like what do we
get the offseasons if we get a little
sloppy and let it go a little bit like
like what was oh we're you yeah that guy
was asking there well you said in the
offseason yeah go ahead go ahead
god no during the season I I tend to get
pretty sloppy and you know you're just
going week to week going against these
monsters and you're just like stress
eating during the week like gosh you got
a balk this guy got about this but
anyway yeah gained weight during the
season a little bit you stress eat I
stress don't eat like I'm like I'm
stressed I can't trade trade but uh
during the seat offseason I tend to work
out really hard and like eat healthy and
I'm looking forward to that all right so
give us a number though I want a
specific number like what was your
biggest you know comment no comment you
have no you have no set thing by the
Colts yet that they're making you weigh
in a certain weight like or did that
start
I don't know I'm giving him free rein I
did as big as you want teams were like
you had it on Friday morning some of the
big guys they had to make a certain way
cuz they were afraid that you know guys
like yeah I see what you we had to make
a certain way you did yes yeah it was
342 uh-huh thank you I was I was more
curious about the sloppy nights what is
a big night out of eating for you
like what's one thing you looked at
yourself in the mirror in the next thing
he said never again cute huh that was
too much uh adore - cheese Cheesecake
Factory one night and it was a lot of
Cheesecake Factory let me tell ya too
bad I woke up the next morning and I'm
like I wasn't even full and I was like
why did I eat all that last night I was
like man like there's just rainbow
containers all over the park pretty much
yeah
and then I'm seeing oh so this is my
idea for you you need to open up this is
left go P R Q sandwich shop in South
Bend right I can do that yeah that's
what used to be more eating spots there
anyway so yeah there's no restaurants in
South Bend Indiana right quit Nelson
sandwich shop yeah call it a kiss it
late night late night that's a good idea
you just I have all the good ideas you
ever had I'll be your partner I'll do
the commercials depending on sandwiches
are you hungry come to Q sandwich shop
he makes him himself it don't don't do
that and then I read that you have a
nickname for McGlinchey what's that it's
a hard-bodied Harry
my heart yeah I don't know if my heart
it's from a movie it's called the fraud
the thing in the movies called the
frogman Bauer okay and yeah you should
watch it one time yeah you called him a
hard-bodied hairy-chested rootin tootin
shootin parachuting demolition
double-cap crimp and frogman yeah rolls
off the tongue yeah for sure yeah
trying to think of the movie it is it's
like a war movie based off a true story
Mark Wahlberg plays the guy it's on the
tip of my tongue yeah I get the guy I
didn't see it but I know the movie
you're talking about I have no idea what
your mark is what trial is the actual
huh what'd you say zero don't know look
up Marcus oral survivor won't survive
survived yeah yeah alright alright so I
want to ask a few more football things
yes I'm always the nerd that does that
like I don't know what Andrew Luck was
like what about Notre Dame like I'm
always intrigued by like what
hell is it there that gets you guys
there like these I mean you guys are
kind of outline you right now between
you Zack Martin Ronnie Stanley
McGlinchey I know I'm missing other guys
but what is it attracts you know your
type of guy so uh for me when I visited
Notre Dame I loved the campus it's
beautiful campus if you ever get to go
see it I visited in the summertime too
so I didn't know how cold winters were
gonna be yeah but uh yeah just get just
getting to meet all the guys and meet
Zach meet Chris walk Chris Froome
Lombard all these amazing guys
McGlinchey hunter BIV and like the
culture and the offensive wine room was
so strong and everyone's there for the
same reason everyone has the same
mindset of trying to get better every
day and we had a great position coach
there and coach he Stan yeah he's with
the Bears now you guys loved him huh
yeah it's awesome
and yeah I would say the culture there
and like the practices were really
intense and like made us better what is
it about an offensive lineman and their
love for their offensive line coach like
I just in my years of my dad and just me
playing like offensive line coaches they
give them like tough love but like they
can make you guys like eat out of their
hands at times like that's how I'm
always amazed that it can be like he
could say tender words at you but you're
still like like he's like your lovable
dad almost so for me like I don't care
if you say any of those things to me
like but what I want out of you is like
someone that cares like a ton of about
like winning and being the best
offensive line we can be like that's
what Cochise ended he came in every day
trying to make us better with the same
mindset he was the same person every
time like intense in the meeting rooms
and his attention to detail and coaching
technique and fundamentals he harped on
all the time and I mean that's what
makes it good alignment is their
technique yeah and someone that just
like cares about being the best as much
as like I do and we did and the other
day
offensive on so you get to Indianapolis
and I don't want he's a competitor and
he's really good Andrew Luck the humours
a competitor and he's right no because I
know he's really good and like but the
the perception from the outside is this
guy is a super nerd with a book club and
he cares a lot and he really but he's
just like all chucks like what is Andrew
Luck like as a guy not as the competitor
and all that stuff yeah I would say
andrew is a he's a nerd I mean every
time we go on a road game it's like and
we get on the bus we're driving to the
hotel it's like we're on a tour cuz he's
just pointing out buildings and saying
oh in 1848 like really up random facts
that are just like awesome and like
sometimes I find it interesting
sometimes I just want to be like beat it
nerd but uh I mean he works his tail off
every single day I don't think anyone
works as hard as he does
on keeping his body healthy being as
prepared as he can for the games on a
Sunday and then I mean just on the field
he's uh he goes from like nerd to like
badass yes pretty quickly dude I mean
like the pictures that were coming out
with him in this offseason where he's
like shredded yeah he's I feel like
Andrew Luck is about to have like the
next three four years is what we've
always wanted for him before all the
injuries happen and your unit right now
do you guys have a nickname for
yourselves no you're not like the Great
Wall of India rising like alia the wall
yeah we don't have a nickname but uh
yeah Andrew is shredded mean yeah not
the hype of my bro talk about him or I
act like got a man crush but I mean his
abs are perfectly proportional and like
he's just sculpted yeah he is especially
for a quarterback yeah now but the other
guy the rookie you came in with Darius
leather I mean your whole class has been
great
his nickname is maniac what about him is
a maniac other than just the speed at
which he plays
I would say on game day he just becomes
a different person legitimately I'm uh
not legitimately
like it crazy but yeah that much of a
crazy person but like he gets into a
zone and that he's just trying to like
make every tackle and go as hard as he
can and he's a great leader for our
defense and for our team awesome dude
kind of like a country boy and he's
awesome did you get like starstruck at
any point this year like lining up like
like I always think of you like really
lining up putting your like oh my gosh
this JJ Watt I'm really about to like
did you have that moment in the NFL
where you're almost like them I'm a
fanboy here I know I got to do my job
but yeah I would say before the game
just like being on the same field as
some of the guys but like during the
game like I can't be thinking about that
I gotta be thinking about my job and
like but who were those guys where you
were a little bit like I would say JJ
Watt was one of them clowny Fletcher Cox
yeah I got your schedule here at
sideways Campbell right I mean there
there's so many guys were you shocked as
like how big coleus Campbell's was when
you saw him in person for the first time
I was shot right I was like what I was
like he's so tall yes and long and I
mean yet he's another strong dude - and
I got to know more at the Pro Bowl he's
a really good dude yeah there's another
guy that just turns it up on Sundays and
yeah yeah did you uh Offensive Rookie of
the Year I feel like it's Yusei Quan and
Johnny man at night Johnny Manziel dude
let me try that one more time I feel
like Offensive Rookie of the Year quit
Nelson is you say Kwan and Baker may
feel he almost said it together I did
yeah I mean I don't think I'm in that
discussion you don't think so now you do
realize that like you're the hope of so
many people that have been like why
can't an offensive lineman win Offensive
Rookie of the Year you can be that you
guys got you got guys like Baker and
sukwon that are just like yeah insane
yeah you're in the discussion yes you're
not gonna win it because it's their star
power yeah well yeah and I mean the runs
sukwon had like oh yeah some of those
were just insane and some of the throws
Baker made like watching it's like put
it in the perfect place and yeah I mean
they're both really special where you're
from Jersey right good we're in the
trust tree right we're good yeah her
friends all right I just wanted to make
sure I as a lion serious question I
didn't eat me in my own show exists
every one of my pets have a really good
Jim Irsay impression I don't think so no
nobody makes fun of the owner on the
team really no his owner hey guys we
really need 31 points guys I'm excited
there's ripping butts in the owners box
he's doing that in the owners box yet
know how he has his glass casing where
he could smoked his cigarettes it's
really cool here's a black box that
sucks the smoke out yes I believe it
yeah I mean he's great though it's like
the owner you want he cares so much
about winning and for he brings a lot of
excitement to the team with some of the
speeches and stuff like that yeah what
about were you surprised because I'm
kind of a fan of your old line coach who
was let go Dave and I'm dig ilmo Google
yeah yeah I always the same niche which
I really am a fan of him I mean III
thought what he did with you guys I know
he's from New England a little bit and
he's pretty top notch were you shocked
that that happened
yeah I think we were all on the office
of wine I shocked because
I mean we just came off a pretty good
year and I thought we really put stuff
together and like we're gonna come back
next year and have it another great year
but uh yeah I think at the end of the
day it's just uh he he was Josh
McDaniels guy right and I mean for Coach
right like I completely understand you
don't this is a once-in-a-lifetime all
right to me of being a head coach and
you want to have like you want to do it
your way
yeah and have the guy that like you
truly truly want and I mean we all love
coach Frank and gonna follow him and
whatever decisions he's made he makes
and yeah did you hear these owners I
mean he's on point with his answers yeah
of course that's why he was the sixth
pick of the draft remember when we were
sitting in that room and we were talking
about all the teams that might draft you
yeah and you were like man I might end
up in Tampa maybe I'm gonna go to
Chicago and meet up with your old Oh
like everyone was thinking about that
were you like was any true option back
then when we think back about that no I
had no idea I was gonna go there and I
remember saying like I think the
earliest I could go is seven and right
then eight and I like I I was really
hoping I go uh like eight because I
didn't know like the Colts were in the
picture cuz they didn't meet with me at
the combine and they didn't do a top
thirty visit with me so as I go
they must not like be that interested
right and then I got picked on draft day
and I was just so excited put on my
Colts hat my cold sad Colts forged and
that was a great night first a gets on
and he goes he Quentin I coached Anthony
munos man they were lying in the weeds
you know it so many times it like Notre
Dame and I even told enough go this last
year like when I would come back with
you the telecast like I I thought the
Bears we're gonna make a play for you to
at eight just because I felt like a lot
of the games when I was out there for
pregame there was somebody from the
Bears management that was there and you
know not that I know but I certainly
felt like they were checking you and
McGlinchey out a whole lot and it's it's
funny of the team that
never expect ya comes and gets you I
mean you didn't have nothing interview
with them and didn't talk to anybody
personally they came to uh let's see
they came to my pro day right Chris
Ballard and Gooch did and after the pro
day I met with them for thirty minutes
and just had a conversation and after
the conversation was up Chris was like
well you're gonna do a good wherever you
go and he kind of made it seem like hey
like good luck like and I was like well
why don't we just have that thirty
minute talk if you're if you're not
interested you're ending the
conversation on like gugak with that
other team or like whatever team you're
gonna be a good player stuff like that
but uh then he picked me meanwhile
there's slow playing so that nobody else
knew they were actually interested no
one would I think no one would trade up
think about who we were sitting with in
that room you mean Derwin and ro Quan
and Darwin's life and fit dirt okay but
sir but Derwent we were like me Derwin
could go as high as five and he went all
the way back there on the teens all
three you guys are kicked ass this year
yeah I remember you saying like Darren I
think he should be like drafted like in
the top ten stuff right and I mean he
had a heck of a year with the Chargers
I'm believing that rope want to did
super well right though yeah it was a
cool crew and the best part was like we
had so much fun and yeah they're all
cool dudes and uh yeah what's the
biggest thing you look at your game from
the Year like any just if you had a self
evaluate right like we do that on here a
lot like self scout where you just go I
need to improve this one area going into
year two getting my hands inside and
pass bro right tell and tell people why
I like more than [ __ ] then yeah because
uh getting your hands inside gives you
leverage and your you're able to stop
them more if I rap outside then they're
into my chest and they're able to like
push me back more right but uh if I'm to
get inside I have have
have my elbows locked in and I'm in a
powerful position it's hard for them to
push me back so hit the punch to to kind
of slow down they're very visually rush
yeah right all right so before I leave
and we kind of toss it out somewhere is
there anything else you want to talk
about that's non-football related
anything else in the world if you want
to be host quit Nelson anything yes all
right and who are you picking in the
game this yeah let's go we're putting
you on the spot there's one other
question sorry I thought I was perfect
no one go Colts go and the other
question is I have two this week for
Thursday's show see if I can throw the
ball 50 yards Sims made a comment a few
months ago that he thinks I can I would
say 95% of the rams last night said no
and I'd say 95% of the Patriots said yes
and I'm curious if my buddy
quit Nelson thinks if I can throw the
ball 50 yards in the air I'm rooting
against it just so you know he's
completely turned I know I mean I said
he could do it so I have no idea what
your athletic capabilities are if you do
want to ask me questions okay what was
your what was your football experience
what positions did you feel like I was
more of a tight end like I didn't play
any formal high school football I play
like Flags excited I'm back in these
talking football right
when was the last time you threw
football damn so the last time throw
football was probably in an airport with
him in like no chance if you're lucky we
didn't do it today cuz there's a little
wind today - that would have totally
screwed with you you still think that I
can I think it's gonna be very close
yeah I see scene right but this stuff
these this is you see the lower hat
stuff and it makes me work in a lot of
naki yard I like doing this twice last
week okay there we go
to work out no I don't think that's
gonna do it inspiration for me any words
of wisdom don't [ __ ] up hey quit you're
the man hang around if you're here at
Dan Tana's we're gonna take a quick
break and
right after this we're having Michael
Vick and DeSean Jackson that's gonna be
in an hour so if you're listening to the
podcast stay with us we're coming right
back alright so Sims it's not often that
we get two guests at the same time yeah
and it's not often that we get two
guests that are both ballers Supremes
all they're super you know that a little
bit more fans of Shonna me do you think
anything cuz of you and me I don't I
mean really yeah how do you do the intro
to intros alright me first of all the
man the myth the legend Michael Vick I
played against Mike I sat on the
sidelines that held the clipboard
against Mike and Mike is the only
quarterback I ever seen in my life on
third and 20 I was like he's probably
gonna run and get the first down yeah
gonna throw a laser and get the first
down and then just Sean Jackson I drew
the shot yeah I am an Eagles fan
and I remember second round pick out a
cow they kept showing this punt return
against Tennessee and I was like man
this guy looks unbelievable and he will
go down as one of the greatest wide
receivers in the Eagles history and
every time I watch them in a Bucs
uniform it makes me sad on the inside
this duo was unbelievable yet like match
made in heaven
right I'll never forget I'm addict I'm
covering a Kentucky basketball game and
it's Monday Night Football and it's mike
vick throwing deep to DeSean Jackson
against Washington and the whole world I
felt like stood still yeah I feel like
you love each other I feel like this was
the match made in heaven
it was the perfect connection for me
because when I was in Atlanta the only
thing I ever wanted was to have a
dynamic receiver I got it I couldn't
count on any time during the game I had
righty-right but he was he was very
young right and then when I got paired
with the Sun even though Donovan was the
start of year before I started sitting
the bench and be like you know
I could just throw one pass I would
throw a really really far and you know
didn't know the next year that I would
get the chance to do that yeah this guy
actually helped me get a new contract I
mean that's what I'm gonna start like
like because I think everybody doesn't
realize as we play that they think we're
a lot alike
oh we just play football over all
fanboys like what was it like for you
right in Philadelphia you're already
becoming your own legend the man
returning punts and ended Giants fans
dreams and all that crap but now you get
now you get Mike in town and who you
definitely grew up going it's Mike right
that's what I what I feel like what was
your thought the first time you saw him
caught a pass from home I mean I think
it was a dream come true honestly
growing up watching this dude what he's
done in Atlanta from you know his early
days here where all these fans is here
we're in Atlanta first and foremost yeah
yeah they love him but right growing up
just watching him play in Atlanta and
think he was able to do as far as you
know mobility and his arm strength was
out the world so I could just remember
the year before we got him like all to
do is when they start asking us like
Andy Reid are two dudes with a stencil
if we get Mike Vick hot with any and
everybody that locker was going next
like if we get my big we're gonna go
crazy like we can be a sumo team so you
know I could just remember that and you
know everybody embracing them you know
it was a couple people who didn't like
it we ain't gonna talk about that
[Laughter]
all right so all right you I mean he had
to be the fastest receiver you had
played to at that point right I mean
earless price up no algae Crumpler the
good thing about playing with algae and
people probably would I'll do saying I
wasn't trying to joke on they told me
how to use the tight end which opened up
the field I learned I developed as a
quarterback right because I started out
working the middle of the field you know
it's like the triangle yeah yeah and you
know found ways to get him involved in
like I said hey riding when he was
really young so when I got to
Philadelphia I had you know DeSean
Jeremy Maclin yeah Brent Celek in the
middle
leshawna leshawna behind damn that's
just like that we really felt like you
know even though I've Vince Young said
it earlier this yeah you know the dream
team coming which went viral and kind of
screwed us up but we did have a dream
team right and we believe that and
that's part of the reason we had a lot
of success was because we felt like we
couldn't be stopped so it's hard to
capture how special you were on the
field but I think it was captured at one
moment this this to me may as a curse
and Mariners know because to be honest
it's like bo Jackson type of immortality
yeah but I'm also curious about this I
looked up your rankings and I almost
think that you're gonna tell me that you
were underrated in some of it so many
people believe I just showed the mat in
2004 and this man right here yes okay
everyone says it's one of the greatest
like characters ever but you are a 95
speed and I know you thought you were
probably faster than 95 got there wrong
right
damn but I think like Mia Chris Johnson
we kind of broke air for like oh yeah
overall so I think what you're like they
gave us a hundred but I definitely gave
him a roughly he could go 100 easy
alright alright right way home what did
you think your throwing power bike when
they had the pass and yes so I mean that
kind of negated everything goes oh wait
I just got it just like have you two
raced in the prime okay in the prime I'm
not trying to be a jerk but I've tried
to hide a little in a race really no let
me lose playing the Dallas Cowboys in
2009 and he caught a shallow cross and a
hurt ankle too you know for you know the
people who don't understand or don't
know it enough about routes yeah this is
a shallow you know a quick route fine
it's really bad hit the ball to the
receiver really quick right and he
caught the ball and I was looking at him
and in a blink of an eye he was right
here and I was still looking in the same
spot but he was like five yards ahead of
where I was looking and it was almost
like like saying a race car right in
front of you and then it was just gone
soon you know you just see smoke I
couldn't I could not I never seen a guy
run that fast on the field I couldn't
believe what I was saying
it's like deceptive with the Shawn too
cuz I can you're wrong so Ryder when a
guy your size like a deer running up
running in the woods like yeah I got a
short time lower body so it's like I'm
running like I'm a six four do but
really you know I'm only like 511 so
right just may already been training at
an early age man to kind of get the most
out of every step so I'm like five years
I'm taking like two steps legitimate
yeah no I don't always notice that if a
and I mean did you always feel like that
was an advantage to you on the field of
times because like the DBS at first not
relieved I don't think film did you
justice right until they saw you in
person well honestly I just think like
as far as like my mentality is why
receiver like it's impossible to be as
fast as I am and to run every route
perfectly right hundred percent so me
like I used to just try to gauge my
speed and one thing like I heard a lot
from BBC lawyers Garmin it like was like
dissenter like you can't really tell
like when you're running in when the
balls in the air
I'd turn to another gear so like I
always try to stay out like 85 and then
once I see that blonde I'm taking off
because I know that defender can't run
as fast as I can't attract that move in
and out his route Center rates I'm
jealous
ja we did some stuff to where I was like
what the hell ever be Chris in a
football game that he played the Tampa
phone Falcons fans you probably know
that they beat us every time I hope I
have the stats yet he's wrong he did
beat yeah you're wanted to say cuz of me
so let's see here here it is that's Sims
against you had 716 two touchdowns six
picks damn sorry
horrible came in one game so I got the
game I lost here against Tampa Bay 559
five touchdowns one pick
but 207 rushing yards 215 that's not
nice
so I have gifts for both of you good and
Deshawn I was looking around and I
thought I think I found a picture of the
two guys that embody you the most in a
different sport so take a look tell me
what you think ai and Kobe hey I love
you this is this is LA right and then I
to me you always were like the Allen
Iverson the football sure nah definitely
um you know that's another cat I grew up
always admiring and watching I mean
watching being under six feet with the
you know heart of a lion and just like
was one of the things when he went out
on the court regardless of somebody
being a 7-footer you know his size he
gonna treat him the same way and that's
the mentality I keep on the field every
time I go out to regard somebody my size
are bigger than me
like I'm like I said five ten five
living at the tallest and I play like
I'm six four so we thought about up
there I'm getting I don't care I feel
like I can talk about the gyms about
them feel whatever you want to call it
i'ma tell you I have them all right
though man but I appreciate it yeah I
see Kobe in my eyes is the best behind
Jordan is the best basketball player
ever a lot of you shoot a huge LeBron
fan I'm like Kobe ain't no smoke appears
he wears what bronze like they're
Jordans yeah he's the only person I
respect Kobe but I am
I'm not LeBron question yeah yeah
five seconds live right I've taken Kobe
okay but the other forty three minutes I
want LeBron but my only thing about
LeBron is he's a frickin nature he's
never been I mean no one ever has this
size and you know the abilities and my
thing is like and crush tongs he's
passing the ball he wants to get
everybody else involved not here you
know but you're looking over to play on
your team
right so my gift for Mike out of the
city of course I did I was looking back
and I was trying to figure out it's
funny cuz everyone's gonna compare you
to Randall and all these things but I
know that this guy is your guy I know
that him and John Elway and Steve I
don't know who else is in this pack but
I know that Joe Montana is one of those
guys yeah so I have not looked in there
but I know that you're a historian of
the game and you appreciate the greats
so who were the quarterbacks that you
grew up and went I'm gonna emulate that
star viously Joe Joe Montana and Steve
Young John Elway cuz the way he came
back in the fourth quarter
I was my dad and then Barry Sanders was
one of my idols too so I just took a
little bit of that Barry Sanders and the
quarterback plan bottled it up and made
it a game he's seven from Elway that's
nothing to say seven from airway yeah I
was eight when I was in Pop Warner and
then this is a funny story house I know
you honestly seven didn't come from Hell
where I started wearing number seven
it's a long story I mean this is someone
I love like I was in my junior year in
high school having horrible practices we
switch schools I went from one school to
another you know the numbers was limited
I was win number one my crosstown rival
was when number one and horrible
practices two weeks and just like I'm
feeling like I'm not just not a good
curry your crosstown okay whatever
one-on-one quarterback all the time okay
and I just wasn't comfortable I was
laying down stretching one day me and
one of my best friend's he was weighing
number seven I looked over and I said
let's switch numbers and from there my
career just took off I felt like a
different player I don't know what it
was something just came over me with the
number seven I became even more dynamic
tonight what was your thought like it
was Andre Harrison Andre Harrison
switched jerseys and stratosphere I had
no confidence I was playing with no
confidence I didn't believe in myself
this is my junior high school
training camp right and two weeks in I
was like let's switch numbers yeah we
traded jerseys and the rest was history
damn that's all I had you beat the
crosstown rival yeah you won that one
yeah no I didn't well you actually that
year they beat us like 49 nothing my
coach had to cut the quarters in the
game oh yeah damn good year any reason
you wear 11 is because of my dad Phil
Simms I wish I could say that I wore one
all it through Pop Warner
were four for one year and when I got to
high school or one got the college where
one so when I went to Philadelphia
number 11 was I can't when I got with us
yeah but I got to do is for some reason
I don't know why I didn't go to 11 but I
went in first right and from there I
made 10 mold like any time I'm gonna
fill I was in Tim mode and then once I
went to Washington I uh Robert Griffin
had number 10 right and they was talking
about switching but dance and I was like
well he got too many jerseys sold and
that never saw is like or I'm gonna do
101 so I went to the number one way so
yeah that's where it's at but yeah yeah
I want to pitch to Sean right I know a
team that needs a speed wide receiver
yeah there's a team that has a chance to
make another run at a Super Ball I want
you back in Philadelphia I'm willing to
negotiate I'm willing to talk to Howie
Roseman or I'd say get this man some
cash Carson Wentz does not have a speed
receiver right let's make this I'll be
your agent I'll be your second age you
can do yeah good you don't lose the free
purse I better talk behind closed doors
you know I don't know when I like trying
really hard
when you were growing up like at
receiver like Mike was talking about
Elway Montana who was the guy that you
looked at in football that you were that
that was your man that you looked up to
it was two guys in particular I'm
obviously number one Jerry Rice well I
say three number one with Jerry Rice
number two Randy Moss and number three
was Marvin Harrison yeah and I like I
was like Mike said he combined Barry
Sanders in order to do so what I try to
do is just combine you know Randy Moss
with his tracking as far as down the
field speed Jerry Rice with his hard
work his you know route Polishness and I
ain't as far as Marvin Harrison why he
wasn't the fastest guy but he could get
in and out of breaks crazy like he was
important you know one of them guys were
once that ball was in the air he knew
how to separate like separation as far
as Jerry Rice - he wasn't as fast but a
lot of guy said he was like running like
four to four three or four but he was
what what a 469 like that yeah once that
ball is in the air you know he was able
to separate to that ball so I just kind
of studied with three games and em guys
and write you know kind of modern my old
guy yeah so I'm growing up and I felt
like every music video there was some
guy wearing a Mike Vick Jersey like I
felt like it was every music video back
then and I'm curious what was was there
ever a person that that was shocked to
see you that you were like wait wait
timeout you're shocked to see me like
did it ever hit you where someone was
like either we're in your Jersey they're
like oh [ __ ] Mike Vick and you were like
what yeah big boy from Outkast
really the first time like I met him
probably in 2002 and I seen him wearing
my Jersey and like when he's seen me he
just went hysterical and I'm going
hysterical too because I'm like do it I
got all your albums yes so very surreal
moments we you you meet people and you
in the same city and you know you all
represent sure you know the same
background same culture same form of
entertainment and you know I just
thought it was really really special but
it freaked me out for a minute because
he was both freaking each other hours
did you have that to to shop not really
man
I mean obviously kind of sorta you're
like Lil Wayne I was able to meet him
and he was like a fan of me like I was a
fan of him I'm like oh shoot Lil Wayne
all this he's older than me yeah right
up there with Mike a little bit but as
far as like me like being a young dude
it's just growing up loving little Wayne
like ya best rappers ever behind jay-z
but I was like man this is Lil Wayne I
met him it's like I'm a fan of you so I
was like we was able to hang out go to
club when I go to Miami and just you
know partying chill away head coach of
the 49ers Kyle Shanahan that's another
team you could yeah to check out Frisco
state taxes crazy is home to so I I
don't know but I mean worst case in
there for anything I would like to kind
of end up in LA oh yeah you know we got
some connections Wow DC but you know
what we'll see how it plays out man
right now I got another year in Tampa so
we'll see our plays I mean I just want
to like alright cuz I'm kind of fanboy
with Mike right I'll be I'm really want
to go off on both you because you're
kind of like urban legends alright you
you really are where I feel like maybe
you debunk some of the normal rules of
the NFL and like you know the step in
line cold here all that because you guys
are so talented that not to say you
could get away with rules but you can
get away with things other guys could
not get away with I mean cuz I do that
you were gonna ball play right that's
the way the NFL works I mean I think you
have a hundred percent correct way of
thinking about it but I think like
Robert well being been able to come to
in my career it's like we've as athletes
professional athletes but having so much
success and early on our career being
pro bows and being some of the players
and done some things that no other
players is that you kind of create that
model and that mold behind it like I
know what it takes to get the job done
right then you have some coaches that
have the old-school mentality right you
got to go to practice
we like there's always one Sunday cousin
between the white lines we do it it
tastes we know what it needs to be done
so it's like I love them inside and I
wish a lot of more coaches and then I
feel kind of take that behind certain
players now the younger players yeah go
go get it but it's just hard man but you
haven't got it because you you know
what's best for you right you're become
a grown man in the end of though it's
not Collegeville buddy yeah like we talk
about this a lot and you know okay
there's only so many times you can run
for three and a day and you don't want
to waste it all on Wednesday practice
the coach doesn't understand that
because he's never run for anything uh
he mastered Friday practice hey Mike
just love it out here too far because he
wanted to be fresh like I'm gonna
protect you I'm gonna don't sometimes I
would say Jack just don't run hard on
this road I'm not coming your way all
right
and that's tell skill your body not to
cut them all - but that that's right
there that shows like camaraderie and
leadership that you have to guys to
understand that not the same thing bad
about anybody else but you have younger
guys that needs them reps on a Friday
we're like they have to see it like I
need to see me throw my heart and I'm
like bro I'm in my 11th year like you
know let's calm it down
yeah that's nobody for Sunday right
having a guy like that like I feel like
in my career right now that's where I'm
at I need a god that understands that
and you know sometimes every rep and
practice you don't need that but as long
as when game time comes you get that yes
there yeah so uh Sims has read one book
in his entire life at a sound
exaggeration and gret it is a JFK
conspiracy book and that is why I
appreciate him did you know that Mike
actually wrote the foreword for a book
no yes that's how much ahead of Hugh he
is I always loved me you had a coach
named Tommy Rieman who was also in the
movie North Dallas 40 right everything
that I've gathered is this dude had a
huge impact on your life
yeah everyone knows you but I don't
think everyone knows this character so
fill me on who this guy is
Tommy ring was my high school coach
father figure I didn't really have a
father figure in my life so when I met
him when I was 14 years old I probably
ask them more questions about life than
football and you know I was just one of
those kids who he knew my goal he knew
my dreams in life was was to make it to
the National Football League and he said
listen there
is the blueprint to get there and if you
follow it I'll make sure that first and
foremost you know you go to college
which is something that you want to do
that's the first step and then from
there it's up to you you know how you
conduct yourself how you play and just
the mentorship from him and my life was
it was enormous it was paramount
I mean it was something I needed at that
time growing up in you know in poverty
the poverty neighborhood yeah where I
just
there was no guidance you know other
than my mom but she was she wasn't a
person that could keep me on track keep
me in line and what did it for me was my
junior year he didn't talk to me the
entire second semester because my grade
point I was dropped so like a 2.2 from a
2.6 and now everything was in jeopardy
and it was all about just what was going
on this school having fun being a man
being a quarterback every all the perks
that come along with it right and he
didn't talk to me for a whole semester
right then and there I knew that he had
my back for life yeah because he walked
right past me in the hallway and once
say anything to me and I'm like this man
says he loves me but he won't speak to
me so he really do love me because he
saw me tough love and it made the world
to me so that's why I wrote the foreword
and that's it that's cool that sounds
like your relationship with Chip Kelly
yeah we really could have been Superbowl
would you say it out loud say Victor
Shaw Jackson Jeremy Maclin LeSean McCoy
since when cell like that offensive line
that had studs it was there to hurts
baby hurts what is it like when you're
on a team and it's like training camp
and you look around and you go we're
about to be a problem like can you just
feel it in the locker room
I think the mentality I think you built
that minutes a day early no cuz you
gotta say like do OTAs you know training
camp like you build a comradery with the
team like everyone that like we're not
just playing together and just go to
work together but like we was really
hanging out
going over each other house is that rare
Viviana kind of stay true kind of sort
of because we assume that y'all just
chill all the time it's hard to come
into a locker room in you know for me
and Mike to kind of rebels and
understand like how he was raised and
how I was raised like being in a locker
room full of 53 and the visuals coming
from different you know prices in her
life like you might get somebody coming
from Iowa he comes from jr. I'm coming
from Los Angeles like it's different so
for us to have that camaraderie we had
and we was built like his his lady was
talking model that like we was really
doing stuff in the community his kids
might like we did that stuff so it was
really like a brotherhood and we just
felt we had some special there for it to
be gone to snap her finger yeah that's
tough man broke up so abruptly that week
it was like traumatized and I went to
New York he stayed sadist a mac-11 went
to Kansas City it was like in your gear
if you got to sum it up in like one
sentence right like yeah I mean I'll
give a straight to you yeah go ahead
real I would just say it's like this so
you have a coach that comes in and
brings in his own stigma or his culture
or has just love to see whatever you
want to call it right and he was one of
the coaches where he didn't believe in
players like it was his system and the
NFL's players that he wins championships
I don't get me wrong like a New England
Patriots they have a system that bill
better check his but they start with
innocence again I'm saying it right and
I just feel like it's players in this
league like you have Tom Brady you have
Edelman you have Gronkowski you have all
these pieces to the puzzle and Chip
Kelly was one of the coaches where he's
like it's my system it's like we like
literally when he was hired kind of like
that when he was hired him me McCoy
Macklin we didn't have starting
positions he was like y'all are being
remodeled tools like I gotta earn your
position there was no big battle is not
over practice ball players yeah true
story just that year I'm laying in my
hyperbaric chamber before preseason game
I never told artists I'm battling Nick
Foles for a star position now I've been
the starter for 12 years
my career now I'm in a battle with some
clearly winning nothing to get snick I
was nothing but respect for him we love
him to death
I'm sending my hyperbaric chamber with
tears coming down my eyes crying because
I'm like I'm gonna do everything I could
for Chip Kelly I didn't show them that
that the leadership play on the field
speaks for itself
galvanized the team when we had a tough
time you know with what happened with
Riley Cooper and I'm like there's still
not enough and it's just a reflection
with USANA saying we we did everything
we could to show him that we'll give you
everything that we got 10% and it was
more about his system and himself than
us and that's why we all just got a bro
that's always but my belief is he didn't
realize he had the perfect player for
each position in his office and that you
can't just replace them with other
people it was never the system okay let
me let me rejoice myself when that punt
from the Giants first of all you brought
him back Mike Vick Giants gates all the
Giants fans especially Gabe wherever
Gabe is I just want to ride in it I'm
sorry but you brought it back but when
the punt went up and it didn't go out of
bounds and run right to you I rewatched
it today and you kind of fumbled it a
little dish but you miss to stop a
fumble dopes are true I just had to set
him up but go ahead finish that's your
question I'm just I'm curious was there
a point where you're like I can't
believe they're punting it to me and
then what was the other point where you
were like I'm taking this to the house
and we're winning this game yeah I mean
first off going back to at 13 seconds
left after the amazing comeback that we
had I mean let me take it back a little
bit so when we is getting our yes our
butts kicked
like 28 to 328 to three we all go into
the locker room we like look this this
ain't finna happen we're gonna come back
out here and the world's gonna see
something totally different so we came
back out in that locker room big ran
some crazy
he was for 4:28 going back to that he
did some crazy stuff
he threw a couple passes of Maclin McCoy
he got involved I got involved in there
like I say
fast-forward to that plant 13 seconds
ever I go out there I'm like there's no
way in America he's kicking his wall you
know I'm like he's gonna kick it outside
the stadium so I go back to I'm like he
not came to me and I see it
Oh My Damn he actually did kick him so
when I ran up to catch it from it on
purpose it went like three yards to the
right so when I picked it up actually
and I filmed the bar they all like went
random all right right when I pick it up
I see like a clear Lane and I didn't
really have to do nothing but stick my
foot in the ground there hit that Lane
Jason Avant made it yeah a pleated block
on the center smacked him in it from
there you know it was like and then you
ran down the end line which because the
rivalry it just felt that much sweeter
too and then the patented DeSean fall
you know I felt like I really was
carried by ego once it is own me I had
the majors over there that when you're
that fast like I would say one of the
greatest plays that Mike ever had
Minnesota Vikings overtime runs to the
left splits the defenders they collide
which if you shot that in Friday Night
Lights two people go that's a little
excessive that doesn't really happen and
you go through and you practically ran
out when you're that fast and you see a
crack it's over
really so don't even think about you
know when you finish I can feel it yeah
that's you know you fast but everything
is just like in football speed so you
always in football most so you see a
first down you just go and then when you
watch the film you like how did I do
that
really you amaze yourself a lot but it's
because it's just an ass didn't know
that can't you Detroit Lions fan
Matthews y'all there are you one of many
right here I can't you put it in like
they don't make football commercials
michael vick experience and like michael
vick experience like its Nikes
basketball commercials right that's what
they do
can you like grasp that now that you
truly i'm if i'm wrong i don't can't
think of a football player that's had a
shoe deal that had a 30-second
commercial i hotel is the only one right
now with the shooting I hated that
commercial to be like that roller
coaster but I appreciate it so much
anyone why did you hate it because I
always wanted a commercial where you
like running through the park and you
running through the neighborhood you
want a video yeah yeah but that's what
what I realize now is that commercial
was it was it was forever life-changing
as far as so a kid who dreamed of
becoming you know the next whoever not
like I was like in the NFL when I was
going damn I want to be my thing I just
thought it was really really commercial
back then but now I look at it and I'm
like people was really receptive of it
and that was oh yeah good move and all
that stuff all right so you guys are
speedsters we marvel at guys like Tyree
kill and all that stuff
who would you say is the fastest player
in the NFL right now I say tire because
I don't really know too many or have
seen too many fast guys let me ask you
this just from this right off it just
like you think about it yeah I mean
who's the DB that when you play right
now you just go damn that's he's a
player I'm not I know you don't fear
anybody but who's that DB right now you
just whether you watch him on film
maybe you haven't faced them but you
just go damn like I see his game and
respect it uh I don't putting you on the
spot I could throw got some names for
you if you want me to just that I don't
really good okay yeah I mean it's hard
cuz i people always ask me who's the
toughest corner you win against yeah are
you going to best but I feel like with
me besides a few players never really
one-on-one coverage like I always had a
guy cover me with hip-hop scene I don't
really give people credit but right one
thing I will say going back to I want to
say like my my Ricky or my second year
in the league
right I played verse to leave and he get
he had like a long strap like he got me
at the Lana I did but he can't no we did
though but I'm a couple years before he
got me up a lot of spirits on my Jeremy
up so he's pretty tough but it's hard to
get people credit nowadays cuz you don't
really find too many dudes this on that
island is playing me Sean was we was
playing against the Jets and like 18
degrees weather and yeah I know if they
have Revis Revis in his pram when he was
Revis Island he ran back to the huddle
about nine times saying please throw me
the ball I got Revis beat and I you know
I'm just thinking you know it's Darrelle
Revis is discharged we beat him a couple
of times that night and then when I went
back and watched the film DeSean beat
him on every single go out to here and
Wow and do you might have quote two two
or three of them but it could have been
a mask on there was the one the wide
receiver came to you and he was being
honest about getting the ball really the
ball I can beat this guy that night he
was like I guess it must have been the
thing with Revis - well I was just
saying like do you feel like it's
sometimes like that with quarterbacks
the coach will tell us all week even
though if you have a DeSean Jackson yeah
they're like we don't want to test Revis
too much like hey that plays into your
head as a quarterback you're like man if
I make one mistake over there the coach
is gonna judge me and go I told you not
to throw it over there was it cuz he he
you beat brevis a good six times like
ran right past Wow
three or four yards easy I remember too
when I was in Washington when I was
playing with Kirk Cousins we play
Seattle Monday night I went for like 150
210 I was on them but I could remember
Sean McMann Jay Jay Gruden telling Kurt
we're not throwing in Richard Sherman
sigh or not though so I went to a sorry
like a couple of times and Kurt wouldn't
throw me the ball I'm like like bro like
I'm open like why he'd not told me to
voice it I can't I can't I says you
crazy I'm out here on his field running
for my damn you know if you better tell
me to
raaah Patriots reps now I'm a la dude
man I got to go to LA even though it's
hard to bet against I know I'm Brady
Mays to go he's one of the best
quarterbacks ever and I hey we'll give
you the hook-up for next season now your
NFL Fox analyst Mike Vick so your pick
is very important now I never bet
against Tom Brady again yeah well I kind
of ruled them out early in the season
yeah sure you know when things didn't
look good like a bunch of turmoil but
they figure it out they always found a
way they do it found a way back and I
don't think Tom's gonna lose two years
in a row B can you believe they bred the
ball 48 times in the AFC Championship
game like that's crazy
yeah planning that championship game was
none like any other game plan ahead all
year they came out in tight sets yeah
panel - mouth full yeah you know one
tight end to receive was two backs and
they ran right at him and at Kansas City
never saw that coming
there was something you've never seen
and I would argue that Mike Vick - Sean
Jackson - guys she'll never see again
can I get a ride guys we got more guys
coming Thursday it's gonna be crazy
you boys Jalen Ramsey might be able to
shut you down he'll be here Thursday tio
guys thank you so much and if you are
listening to the podcast right now we'll
be back tomorrow for Sims
he sat homey for Vic beats out for
DeSean neither for federic evening and
for the lef koe we will holla holla
holla at you later be well everybody
thank you again everybody
[Music]